الان الى هذه الصور اذا من صور التلفزيون
الايراني
من محافظه كارمان انفجار قرب الطريق
المؤدي الى قبر قاسم سليماني في محافظه
كارمان اذا واضح صوره الانفجار في المدى
حيث تتصاعد اعمده الدخان هذه المحافظه حيث
دفن فيها قبل اربع سنوات قاسم سليماني بعد
عمليه اغتياله في بغداد مع ابو مهدي
المهندس وا اليوم هي الذكرى الرابعه اذا
لعمليه الاغتيال هذه
وتحييها
ايران عن طريق
مسيرات
وتجمعات
وواضح من خلال هذه الصور للتلفزيون
الايراني بان هناك
انفجار ويتحدث عنه التلفزيون الايراني قرب
الطريق المؤدي الى قبر قاسم سليماني في
منطقه
كرمان بانتظار المزيد من
المعلومات نتابع هذه
الصور صور اخرى اذا لهذه التجمعات
والحشود وهذه المسيرات في الذكرى الرابعه
لاغتيال قاسم سليماني عمليه الاغتيال تمت
في
بغداد
في عام
2020 في عهد الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب و
تمت تفجير سيارته باستهدافها حيث كان
يستقلها عند مطار بغداد هو وابو مهدي
المهندس وقتلا في ذلك
الاستهداف والان التلفزيون الايراني يتحدث
عن انفجار اسوان غاز قرب الطريق المؤدي
الى مرقد قاسم سليماني في محافظه كرمان